hey everyone I'm Ilana and welcome my
channel where today I'm showing you a
bunch of gameplay from the outer worlds
I got to play the game a couple of weeks
ago almost a month ago now and this is
basically gonna be an edited down
version of my impressions but uh yeah
there is a bit a little bit earlier than
this that's fully embargoed so I did get
to play the opening part of the game and
create a character and do all that fun
stuff but I've got a lot of talk to you
about any of that just yet because they
wanted people to experience it fresh so
well I don't know part way through the
game we're only allowed to stay on this
one planet and right now I'm heading
into the main town or one of the towns
in this area which is called full Brook
and right now I do not have an active
quest I've been told to go into this
town to find one but first I thought I
would talk to some of the locals just to
see what happens so as you can tell it's
very upsetting and it looks very much
like Fallout New Vegas or any obsidian
game the way that dialogue plays out is
suit up so thanks Mortimer and it is
worth learning a big part of the lore in
this game is that people are lots of
different corporations that act a lot
like the factions in New Vegas did and
they're very loyal to that corporations
and they speak in the weight of that
corporation has told them to speak it's
a very driving pot of the personality of
the people that you meet in the waltz
and gaining favor with some corporations
and losing favor with other corporations
and I guess it's kind of up to you to
decide that morality let's see if
everyone's just driven by the same
amount of greed oh my god xp for
discovering a vending machine that's
exciting
oh that yeah that's a nice glitch you
can see right there is my companions
that's Nyoka trying to reach me and
running into a staircase
yeah idiot there's something kind of
wild about like spending time in the Baz
and Red Dead Redemption and then going
back to a game like this that is
obviously a lot more full of RPG
mechanics when it comes to leveling up
the character and how you interact with
the well based on what you've built but
it still feels so empty it's it's crazy
this is who I was looking for Catherine
I love her why is it every [ __ ] who
strolls to my town expects me to smile
and shout awful friendly
welcome to a fall she still did it so
Katherine's gonna give us a quest we had
thing that happens I'm not sure if I
like it yet or not go companions
sometimes just turn to you and interrupt
the conversation I do it can be a little
bit strange so what she's telling us to
do right now is basically to go and take
over someone else's Factory so you kind
of have the option to side with her do
exactly what she wants will meet with
clive and have a conversation with him
of course to her we're telling her we're
gonna support her
yeah we're ultimately going to deal with
Clive she is telling us two of the
options going goes guns blazing or
crawled through a sewer pipe that stuff
depends on your skills and other side
quest you ship that you've done so you
won't necessarily be able to do it but
even from this one quest it did feel
like there are a ton of options and I
will both show you some ads other quests
other than this one in fact because this
quest is already available online that
develop is it a walkthrough of it I'll
probably do a pretty truncated version
of this one and just jump through it
really quickly this is Makos combat
encounter sounds pretty dumb
be strong though this is a thing called
tactical time-dilation that lets you
slow down time I think it goes fossa
depending on how fast you move like and
that's one skills you can opt rate so
that it runs out slower or refills
foster or whatever else can approach
this stuff great stealthily I just
didn't
I guess when I'm training I throw a game
to capture pup says you don't want to
but uh yeah there are full bosses boys
builds that focus on stealth for sure I
always go to check behind a waterfall
mother Logan's and thankfully I was
actually able to up in it so that's cool
also I love these character screens
these Anatomy screens I thought that was
so cool
the creature design in this game is
pretty doll and now we are inside the
facility and gotta look for
slaughterhouse alive before the record
the way that I approach this is way
different to the way that it does
approach this I tried to stealth Roo I
think I failed but they will like hack
and [ __ ] I did not do any hack and [ __ ]
because I wasn't prepared with that with
that build
see how cool that salt is love
sneaky [ __ ] so if I had medical level 45
I would be able to mess these 60 picks
up pretty badly by feeding them way too
much I guess but I didn't have that so I
couldn't I think and I guess doing that
would make people freak out I don't
really know what the reaction would be
but um it would obviously mess up
Clive's supply one breach poles inside
of the factory was a walk bench
I discovered a workbench so yeah if you
look through it you can give this
goddamn thing a grip which is dope but
it's mostly about adding modes tinkering
and repairing and you can also basically
dispose of stuff like break stuff down
but yeah these are all the weapons I
have right now as well and then we
continue without mayhem so I did manage
to stealth my way through this
particular pot and I found alive that's
him terrifying again there are a lot of
other options you can decide with him
silently no I killed you boy I really
hit him with a sword and then shot him
to death yep so finish the quest head
back to Fallbrook to return to Catherine
well I don't know Matt [ __ ] is
dead that I might have take that to mean
you didn't kill him so she gave me a
bunch of money I got a bunch of xp for
it bit cartridge rocks clump whatever I
don't know what those things up but I
also demanded a yeah a VIP suite and
this is the Fallbrook domicile
yeah just a place where I can stall stop
sleep notice a bunch of wood in here
resting in a bed moves time so I didn't
sue Panay you can only rest in your bed
on your ship the unreliable which I
don't even know where the ship is in
this particular play 3 right now
so here I went through and looked at
some of the items that I have I feel
like my character looks pretty stupid
right now but I don't know how cool you
can make them look it's it fits in the
wall they suppose but yeah I was just
picking stuff that had the best Alma
etcetera and then I thought I'm gonna
show you guys this bit just cuz it's
pretty I just kind of wanted to take a
look around obviously not as dense as
some modern games but I feel like the
variety of environments even if it's
really short space it is very cool and
again thank you for putting something
behind the waterfall we all really
appreciate it
I'm creeped it's better here I don't see
them just standing there oh that's
something but yeah I clearly don't have
an active quest right now so I was kind
of just exploring it is I think it is
pretty like I don't feel like the
graphics are particularly impressive
which I guess is how it's gonna run on a
Nintendo switch but I think the design
makes this game pretty oh and then
character inventory it's out tributes
this is just the summary as you can tell
there are skills pucks and details and
reputations he's going through skills I
think I just got this for capture
purposes but it's handy to to show you
guys too that this is what all you basic
skills look like yeah there's a lot to
read and a lot to commit to and that's
what I'm most excited about when it
comes to this game is I think that we're
gonna be able to build some highly
specific characters I feel like the puss
and I play as it's going to be
dramatically different to what other
people play as and that goes for looks
as well so these are pucks none
available right now but basically once
you've unlocked 5 and Tiye 1 then you
unlock to it to where they get a little
bit more traumatic or a little bit
crazier see there's some that are really
specific to
the time-dilation stuff which I think
I'll end up using dialogue skills I
think I'll end up using a ton of that to
consumable weight companion abilities a
lot of companion stuff in here they seem
pretty proud of those details I guess is
just my current character stats and
reputation is gonna be how I am with a
different group sublights Alvin and
shipping I think likes me because that
might be what they didn't like me
because I hope took the factory but uh
the sub like salvaged shipping i think
is what Katherine is a part of so I
think this is where I found my next
quest yeah with this fine gentleman not
at all how he sounded sue this find Andy
gives us a quest you can borrow with him
for the outcome which is cool basically
he's putting drugs inside of sprats
which I like rat it's kind of 5% Punk
ridiculous how quickly the character
breaks I do like the characters in a
while I feel like they're all very
distinct and like well fleshed out and
well scripted I like it so yeah he sends
us to such sublight shipping tunnels for
his missing sprats who are holding drugs
I don't feel like this is that wacky for
obsidian but it is kind of in line with
this sense of humor Nate I do feel like
a lot of that humor is sprinkled out
throughout this the whole time that I
played this demo I appreciate it
one thing I will know and this was a
good example like the games pretty easy
I'm sure that I have this point make
expect this really high to drop us in
this part of the game so we could get
through it so we want dying and of
course they're all going to be hard
difficulties and the one we're playing
here but yeah I didn't find any of the
comment account it's difficult
little tiny sprats so pretty simple we
head back to nelson give him dem drugs
as you do I love the student voice
acting still so I just hit him in the
face great I guess we'll have to find
out you got a real mystery on our hands
no clean who stole the rest of the drug
runners I mean Kerry is definitely just
carrying us alright hey little guys how
y'all doing
they're actually pretty cute I think
that pretty cute well you were the one
who had it open so that's a Todd Lee
seems fair damn it all now look what
you've done
it'll take me ages to round him up again
I don't know what this man is I don't
know what his like why he looks
different no no don't know what race he
is but yes he is rescuing these tiny
critters clearly causes a problem for us
Nelson was that it was ID I don't care
if Nelson sent you or not you won't be
hurting a hair on any of these sprats
heads
I've killed vicious beasts for him I
ain't afraid to take on a human test be
fighting well that's John mesial hands
up or become Spratt food intruder damn
so yeah three options then
I went with a pretty simple one get your
drugs get lost which is to dig through
literal [ __ ] to get my drugs back that's
how important it is to me
Nelson again I just like this quest I
think it's it's really simple it's easy
it doesn't require any combat at all but
I felt like it had a lot of personality
and having this sprinkled in with quests
that do require a lot more walking or a
lot more people means I'm probably gonna
really like the way that this game is
balanced in terms of quests all right
back to Nelson got all those drugs I'm
here so yeah my reputation increased I
got to a friendly point with them I got
some hot XP and I have lost item name
timez5 love a pre-release build so at
this point again no active quest so I
just basically left Fallbrook I think is
the name of the place wanted to find
another location before I had to stop
playing this interaction I think is cute
- it is chatting
sounds cute yeah I do feel like the
companions have a fair amount of
personality we only got to see these two
hopefully we can get you know some crazy
aliens companions and stuff
giggle time dilation
Hey level up I guess that's some killing
a bunch of little critters
yeah gave me ten points though that's
pretty hot
that ain't bad and I went for dialogue
because that's what I like to go for
yeah once you've hit fifty on one of
these I think then you're allowed to
level it up individually so like you
could see that I could level up hack
individually because it hit fifty so if
I leveled up dialogue two more times I
would be able to level up lies points
individually I hope that makes sense and
I got another perk but only one point
for a level up and obviously that's just
on one level you can level each Park up
more
I picked this randomly didn't have any
reason to go there I just wanted to find
another location before I had to stop
playing and I'm actually pretty glad I
picked this one I like it and here's
some interesting stuff going on this is
another faction or corporation or
whatever you want to call them you'll
find everything you need to know about
Graham his philosophies truths and the
iconoclast way and it's a [ __ ] cult
so that's cool so we head straight to
cult daddy Graham I found it to be a
really weird way to pronounce that name
in Australia we say Graham in America
they say Graham and it sounds like
someone just saying grandma but
shouldn't hey Graham and there he is and
there she is
Mama and Papa cult stranger again
they're all just kind of good-looking if
you were looking for a path to walk you
Quigley Styles if you're looking for a
chops but still an attractive face
welcome what would you like to know
they're always so just like creepily
polite and all of these cult bros
joining the universe the universe came
into being over time
ganic Li naturally and without purpose
in that sense I suppose you could say
that in the interest of least I agree
with him on that so yeah uh talk to
Graham what about cult stuff I could
show you guys this whole interaction
like I went through and blend it all but
I figure I wanted this video to be a
little more educational I don't want to
take any learning experiences away from
me so I'll probably cut through this but
yeah you can learn a ton about the
iconoclasts about the cult about what
they believe and what they do and how
they all feel about stuff alright so at
this point I got myself requests boys
basically they need help because of
course they don't because this is an RPG
that's how it's how you meet someone
they tell you their life story and then
they ask you to do an errand for them
yeah they basically need the press to be
operational again so they can print
their pamphlets so yeah we just have to
fix it up and they lost their runner we
got to try to find and so the chaos and
cheese if you need me I'll be in I guess
he wants you to buy rounds she wants you
to buy food and medicine but as it says
that's an optional part of the quest the
main thing is you have to go meet
cholera and get the printing press rail
is the other stuff is optional but but
obviously help out the colony and I
guess pick sides between them I imagine
if you really pursue the iconic lost
quest that you have to take aside
between those two cult leaders at some
point I mean it's already built up the
second you walk into their argument
constantly so again it was a town that
had its own low very different to the
other towns law and then when you get
there to try to meet with quwata who I
met with Niles who done want you there
so this is an interaction I had to talk
my way through again I don't know I just
think all these characters unique and
interesting and I buy them as people who
I was impressed with that part for sure
impressed with the writings are I like
the dialogue options here pretty sassy
it's it's
great why are you asking me questions
instead of sucking sulfur get out of em
he got mad walk on in all right
took a risk you tried to lie to him and
it worked so yeah basically everyone
left that could have been a full-blown
fight but uh that well-placed lie or
maybe the way that I had made those
interactions work made them will get the
hell out of there
but that sublight as well we don't to
piss them off remember because we made
them friendly with us already so yeah so
we get inside meet Cole Otto again
pretty hot unexpectedly hot yeah I'm
gonna do it Thanks so she's basically
like a the supply runner and um yeah she
got him she's not doing it again
choice between Graham missoura which do
we want high-capacity daata I guess is
what I went for it I remember doing that
what I did so then obviously got a run
back to Graham and the iconoclasts we
got his print and press he can make his
pamphlets got some rounds whatever I'm
sure that figuring out how they get food
from other sources will also play into
it depending on how much time you decide
to spend in that area I don't know dude
I'm already just super caught up and
this games law so then we return to
Graham he is still arguing with aura
naturally they don't just abandon orders
and they weren't at the ruins so long to
notice I was bad she's disappointed
again I'm interested in this conflict I
get the message is important what's
always eating look just
if the vert noise are still alive get
them out of there with Sanjar pressing
the issue like this I have a feeling
we'll need them and that is the end of
my gameplay folks I'm Alana thank you
guys so much for watching and let me
know if you have any questions see you
guys next time bye